hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to pray now I know it's
been a while since the last episode but
with the charity livestreams that we've
been doing it has been a bit difficult
to record pray again but I'm back in the
thick of it and I'm starting to get the
hang of the game only 9 or 10 episodes
in whatever it is now but I got to get
over to the reactor oh hi hello oh I've
already searched your corpse good for me
but now oh that's right the other way is
now open or at least it should not be
possessed by these typhoid and what's
really weird is why are the typhoid
typhoid
Tyshawn able to hack into actual
electronics like this was just a control
panel to open a door and yet a Typhon
was either integrated in it or had
somehow become integrated in it now
there may be a kind of a third step in
the middle here going on because it
seemed like the Typhon that i just
fought was a sort of electrical hybrid
like it was it was affected by my
electrical attacks because it was
machinery that was more of you I can
track you through your bracelet and
guide you from here okay good thing I
still have a bracelet around on me oh hi
why are you in that control room can I
sneak a recycler charge like right in
there that would be super cool if I
could do that
[Applause]
now that was an effective use of a
charge unless they all blew up and I
actually didn't get anything out of it
but you know frankly that actually took
care of them pretty well so I'll cut my
losses for what they are and I'll take
what I can get see if I can even get in
here oh good it opened up yeah well that
is not much stuff but at least it
cleared that out a little bit a good cop
bad cop yeah I know about back loot
canister you don't have that but I can
hack this little I gotta be on the up
but I got away all the way on the other
side I gotta wha what are you gonna make
me go so far what do I got a whine and
complain about everything but I gotta be
such a giant [ __ ] about everything
alright that we're gonna think Oh danke
what are we gonna burn so got more crew
around here but that's not why I'm here
I'm Eve here for the utilities this and
the engineering control which I can only
assume is gonna open that door
and tax oh oh objective complete oh hi
hello who's in there
oh you're nothing you're just a normal
one but they figured out how to use the
elevators which is kind of nice for them
and not for me in any way which is
usually how these things go uh-huh
uh-huh uh-huh
nothing in here alrighty then whatever
you say what are you what are you thanks
why me you're a light obviously but uh
hey I can use a little bit of a suit fix
up if you got the ability to do that I
kind of need it please I'm desperate for
it thank you
oh there was already one other
engineering clothes thank you
I'm more confused to where that guy's
going anyway also before I move on to
far I'm actually gonna use my neuro mods
because I've got 13 of them now I want
more of these things there is the
Phantom shift which is kind of nice
there is also telepathy here but I don't
know how much longer I can keep using
these and keep going but at least at the
very least I can upgrade my blast
because my blast is the one that I use
the most to be perfectly honest and I
need to get another nightmare the
nightmares the big thing right I don't
want any of that but then there's a
general stuff like oh yeah that's good
that's one it's only one so I might as
well use it
combat focus I don't know how to do that
but that seems kind of cool but you know
I'm gonna does not do that sneak attack
oh the twenty fifty percent more that's
five that's five let's do oh that's nice
natural lifespan increase by 25 years
what that's awesome oh that that sounds
great
I'll live longer just plain ol live
longer that's awesome okay so at least I
spent the nura mods that I have and I'm
not going too deep into the neuro mod
field with all the other stuff and I
still got an upgraded kinetic blast is
gonna help me through this hello Brenda
Cabrera you're not doing too well
well that's electrified and that all
looks real bad down there and there
seems to be some sinister music that I'm
sensing from behind this door deployment
resuming all right cool whatever you say
hello good God
yeah boy you were looking for me yeah
what's the story on Mikayla's office I
filed an incident report well I'm sure
it's a page-turner but I don't have time
I need to get a crew on the other side
of that breach so what's the problem
problem is it's blacker than my butthole
at the bottom of it well in there the
grounding resistor malfunctioned swap a
new one and you should have your lights
oh wait
you sound rattled oh no what the hell
yesterday what the hell was that about
melted into some kind of goo it smelled
like fried ass [ __ ] man that's not no
report is it I need to get some sleep my
shifts over anyway maybe you'll have
better luck yeah they didn't sound good
yes your Luck's gonna really do you
about that I'm unfortunately quizzer
tutorial about this yeah unfortunately I
don't have repair three and I could have
gotten that if I did just win do more
stabs to be able to do what I need to do
because oh my god there are neuro mouths
right there but it's outside anyway so I
wouldn't been able to do that I can go
through here too
give me what you got ooh I don't know
what the Lightning is coming from but I
think it's coming from behind yeah right
behind that panel so going out there
would be death because I don't think I
can turn the corner and glue it once I
can here we go blue blue whoa oh and uh
broke my gun okay that was dumb let me
just reload that one because that was a
whole lot of dumb all right let's just
pretend like none of that happened and
I'm not an idiot and I'm gonna do this
right this time okay let's go down here
hello is it darker than my butthole at
the bottom of oil down here yeah hi
honey honey I do
yeah I see you over there oh hey oh
that's a lot of them that is it whoo
there's a lot of them well I don't think
those turrets are friendly they seem
like they might be a whole lot of yeah
they got the red lights on a mooch makes
me think there are in yeah or hacked up
spends more the way I got to get over
there and that guide works none too
friendly why is that guy not getting
shot by the I guess I was dead I thought
you electrostatic absorption I sure
could use that when they're attacking me
oh I keep doing that
I gotta stop doing that I mean it was a
nice sneak attack but I didn't want to
do that yeah hey I don't think he knew
this tune did that it's gonna be okay
I think my glue just sucks in all the
fire certainly as a useful ability but
not something I need right now
ooh God they were coming to all hey no
you know I don't think you need to
bother about me I don't think it was
actually me that did that to you
I gotta get better stealth because I'm
not very stealthy yeah who's he ow my
ankle bones all my bones got smooshed
into my body
don't mind the goob oh my Margaret is
slinging this what was that oh hi oh god
that's a body
did I just goof a body out of the wall I
think somehow oh it wasn't out of the
wall it was just there a little bird
told me you plug a leak in an
unconventional manner a few weeks ago
yeah was it an ass-kissing bird named
crass a cough
maybe care to elaborate not if I'm going
to get my peepee slapped worse I'll dunk
you in the eel tank
ouch no supply was out apart so I
borrowed a glue gun from the guys in
hardware worked out okay ingenious next
time let's make sure we have enough
spare parts to do the job right
okay all right boss roads are their
bowls you got about no don't lock that I
need to go through there I know there
was an enemy on the other side of that
but I need to be brave you need to face
him
and bigger I'm going to smack you you
know back of the noggin you're just a
normal right now if I sneaky sneak on
you what are you looking at in there
there's someone in there that you're
trying not to kill we're trying to kill
I don't know either way you're gonna get
swing swung Blanco block Blanc and then
a shotgun because this seems to be
largely ineffective you know I would
have thought that my my swing swans
would have been a little more oomph e
than that but apparently that was not
true but it looks like I can LUN lock
one of these unless the locks down is
still in effect is it
maybe I don't know about that
man that whole lockdown that my brother
put up yeah it's still yeah security
lockdown Tallis 1 exterior yeah I can't
go out there just yet because
everything's locked as soon as I do I
need to go to over to the neural mount
Department so I can get the frickin
neural mod plans unlocked otherwise you
were in the med bay
how did you die oh well obviously a
mimic but oh this guy was broken you
could have just rented a new one buddy
boo you didn't have to wait around for
death to take you sadly I am the smarter
of the two of us because I'm still alive
ignore the fact that I've died many
times but at least I have more help now
which is kind of odd eonni I do whatever
what about her time okay huh yeah that
really bass this up very good mouth full
sealed so strongly I wonder if they're
trying to go whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa where the Frankie you [ __ ] come
from the heck god I do not check things
I just don't I'm a dumb like that I need
to check everything but it's just like
it's kind of hard on electronics by
working through a series of practical
experiments this humble manual will
introduce you to the fundamentals of
modern analog and digital electronics by
the Anna you will be able to construct
any simple circuit Thomas Edison once
said to invent you need a good
imagination and a pile of junk great
doesn't help me in my scenario around
here and there's a lot of red dots out
there lose him like oh hi you're alive
that's why he was staring in there and
repairs needed what contest mollified
engineer I thought I was going to die
well sooner than I thought I was going
to die where did that thing come from
was it told me the way it was looking at
me I get up except for my legs and my
lungs my nervous system don't look
surprised
power plexus remember you warned me
the Boosters are in my office no way I'm
getting there now
at the rate I was serious before I think
we can bypass the lock down the reactor
control room there's a panel for
shutting down every notion the computer
will scream at you but just do it then
pray it all comes back when you cycle
the power it should it will no go man
are you gonna be okay here because I
should be sure to lock this in because
if I if I just leave these out and don't
lock the door you're probably gonna get
killed like I'm willing to bet that's
how that's gonna work so I'm gonna be
sure to lock that and not let anything
in here oh god someone bled explosively
right there alright let me go in the
computer first because I oh ever
can I still hack into it if there's an
error would I not be able to do that any
other room yeah would I not be able to
do that otherwise okay here we go
hey LAN krasnikov just raid quit the
battle ops League so we have an open
spot you still want in to show up at the
usual time in the reactor room I'll have
enough parts you can get bash and
remember not a word of this in front of
Brooks really ssin they don't know and
we want to keep it that way let's see
what do we got here
Talia as I stated in the official report
up replace the grounding resistors in an
attempt to restore power to illusions
office whoo oh okay thankfully oh the
resulted in a powerful electrical
explosion and subsequent structural
damage that exposed the office to vacuum
and thankfully the bulkheads sealed
breach the faulty resistors immediately
melted into a short of shapeless
smoldering and seemingly organic matter
assume all parts and storage are suspect
ah that's really interesting so the
grounding resistors were actually a
mimic but that mimic got put into an
electrical circuit and got fried to [ __ ]
that's kind of funny understood I'll
have some of the engineers inspect the
stuff in storage so these things how
long were the mimics like in the
facility just hiding among them like did
they all like slowly bleed in through
everything disrupter battery cool I've
had the disruptor for a while but I
don't think I've been able to charge it
gonna lock that up boo boo boo boo okay
so I just need to go down here and I
need to do something but how long were
they in here the only way that it makes
sense that they were able to actually
remember but she remembers you she hid
her condition to work aboard tell us one
when you found out she should have been
sent back to earth but you made an
exception I'm not sure if that makes you
responsible now she won't last long
without her medication it's up to you if
you want to help her that's a little
that's a little that's a little wool
thank you for that apparently okay
that's a little so I was gonna help her
anyway but you didn't need to be so
robotic like what is good what is bad
about it but anyway so the only way that
to make sense that these tie phones were
able to actually take over the station
is if they were all coordinating getting
into position so that they would
actually be able to attack and be
successful because that's the problem
right that's the problem there is a
security response and there are turrets
that are specifically designed to shoot
down Typhon like they're designed and
programmed for that to seek it out like
they had security systems that were
ready for it but it seemed like half the
staff didn't even know what they were
doing here you know what I mean that's
cool
looking that is big a real big I could
probably jump down there but I don't
think I want to do that unless I want to
be a badass and yes I do
all right what's this oh yeah oh yeah
jetpack oh so great okay oh hello he can
I make it over there no I cannot oh yeah
oh my god I can't okay so I got guy
crawls reactor access which is awfully
good there's a little bit of radiation
over here but I think this is because
I'm by the reactor yeah so the only way
that it makes sense is if those Typhon
have slowly been bleeding out and people
were just ignorant enough that they
didn't know what the Typhon we're gonna
do and in the end they got in position
to be able to attack everything and just
devastate the station whoo there's some
red turrets in there I can act this
though I think I got a level three right
I remember correctly huh let's go here
we're gonna go man ooh all right Little
Italy Italy [ __ ] you oh do we eat my
paint all right they're real boo boo boo
oh oh oh that's plenty of time for that
mana I'm kind of upset about that they
made a little too easy for me
I'm not mistaken they're these look like
they're evil because they're all glowing
in Riyadh right whatever god I gotta
hack another thing this one unlocked no
the Bolton unlocked
okay fine man laetus I'm ready for
anything anyway so let's just go do
Toledo is Italy I don't know why why in
the world would I need to engineer
dispensers I mean from a logical
standpoint they do a lot of universe
building and of course they would have
like they would have a lot of engineer
operators in the reactor room because
they need to repair a lot of things some
question they didn't expect anyone to
just be like fixing up their suit when
they do this now which is kind of a
stupid murder trans car I must need this
for something because this is glowing
and so I'm gonna put it out there can
you do another thing
the thing where you scan me and
bluebottle my suit for me thank you very
much I could do that at least you got a
weapon upgrade kit so I'm assuming
they're preparing me for something here
because these are a lot of a lot of
turrets here and I'm not sure what they
want 100% but I'm pretty sure it means
that I'm about to fight and deploying if
the red does that mean that oh okay all
right I thought I thought I thought fora
more certainty that the red means that I
was gonna be dead please listen I had
too much Typhon material in me after
that one upgrade and then it was just
going to be bad so I don't know where
the fire is gonna be coming from I don't
know where the tie farms are gonna be
flooding in from so I'm just gonna set
these up as best I can and kind of hope
was usually all that I can do anyway so
no no this seems seem strange huh what
no no I'm not going on don't do that do
I have to hack every one of these oh my
god well you're such a sack of ass
they're just a big old soggy sack of ass
you son of a oh oh look
no just go down oh well this is gonna be
a pain in the donk
so I officially with that one upgrade I
got a little too far and unfortunately
now I am more alien than I ever wanted
to be although I kind of figured that a
drop same as anything else when it comes
to these things just a little bit a bit
alien is probably very bad unless you
went through the whole security route
and then you weren't an alien and that's
the only way to really win or something
like that either way it's not doesn't
smell good for me
bloke
hurry up come on
later later later whoo hello where'd you
come from
alright and then I got some duplicates
here blorp and Bloor and then I got a
lot of SU repair kits but I don't need
synthetic material that's the one thing
that I really don't need mmm yeah but I
got a lot of these things so toss those
away and I think I'm good too de Lube
wait for your leader leader leader
leader give give give okay so I got
those and now enough stalling and
preparing because I'm not gonna bother
hacking the other ones because they're
just gonna be a pain in the ass to do
that but I am gonna go in here I am
gonna see well restarting this reactor
and I don't know what's gonna happen
because it looks like there's a lot of
hot glowing metal over there oh god they
are loading me up for something this is
going to be a BIOS fight it's gonna be
one hell of a BIOS fight they stay got
two turrets ready it would probably be
moving me to do more oh boy ooh ten
sixteen seventy six safety control
switches for all the main utilities must
be placed in the off position in the
following order before initialization
reactor shutdown Magneto's fear
substation photovoltaic rings gravity
life support and then main reactor I'm
not gonna remember those but I'm gonna
try magneto sphere substation folder
Balak gravity life support main reactor
so M s pH MS fook gravity life main I'm
not gonna remember that okay I'm gonna
try oh my brain I put him right in there
okay accent safety switches oh I don't
even need to do this I can let's look it
up see if I remember all right so I need
Magneto's here
[Music]
this substation full take yeah that's
right substation voltaic gravity yeah
rowdy like sport nine got it no what a
puzzle that was reactor shutdown
sequence location yep a little tear
greens yep nice that's probably not good
in three two one
reactor successfully shutdown initiating
main reactor ignition sequence in three
two one magnetosphere morning reactor
initialization interrupted at morning
just a week ago I got a diverter over
there
I got a diverter I know her diverter is
oh there was a crafty craft right there
I didn't even know about that I'll have
to fix that later but right now I need
to yeah I need to get this diverter and
I need to take it somewhere I don't know
where but I'm going to do that where oh
do I actually have to go in the thing or
do I just got to go to the back of the
thing looks like I have to go in the
thing good thing it's off and not gonna
incinerate me with its reactant material
which I can only assume to be lava why
do I got to go in there why do I gotta
go in there with all those sons of
[ __ ] okay maybe I can do this oh
that's not what I
to do it all but maybe I can do the same
trick that I did before maybe actually
gonna know that didn't hit him on oil
right fine
try the thing I did with the recycler
charge again oh no no no hey look at
that
my guys helped out that was awfully nice
of them so where does this diverter go
they're more you guys in Aaron why were
you oh it is very irradiated in here
okay let's his goop lamp is on the
freight lift as requested
I asked Connolly to send them down when
convenient boys oh wow
I have anti rad pills for this I just
remembered those things that I got and
I've never used ever
blorp did that do it am i good I'm good
I'm so good about that I'm the best when
it comes to that thing that I do about
that and I don't have any power here so
there was no point even repairing that
just yet at least I should be able to
turn on the main reactor now and get all
my worried about now
oh that doesn't seem good at all
I'm judging by the smoke in the
explosions that things worked oh ah
that's okay all right then I know what
gun to use for you yeah yeah yeah spikes
and leaks in the coolant chamber
watch yourself on the way back there
could be other structural damage yeah it
didn't seem to work out so well themes
like everything blue alright first wow I
see you said everything yeah I did yeah
Aswan is wide open now clever reckless
but clever it's good to see some things
haven't changed
yeah Oh whatever you gonna get in your
way anymore you deserve to hear the
truth all of it okay good luck girls
alright whatever you say man you know
just take it for what it is that you
whatever you did I felt it in my gut
if this is some kind of payback her
towers coming back online huh and that
means the main lift - I hope payback
what is it person have such a such does
a stick up her butt about me what did I
ever do to her nothing that's what I did
I don't know what this is but uh I'm
gonna get it cuz why not
yeah cool hi wow how did you not spot me
how did you not are not much gonna try
to bolt me I don't know if I'm gonna be
able to get out of here without them
noticing me there is a distinct drop in
frame rates over up there well I'm not
gonna look at that direction because
it's just bad all around for me okay
who's digging oh so sneekly okay which
way to go up just follow this one so
don't think I have to fight him I don't
actually have to fight everything that
comes along my way but those seemed
probably gonna give me a lot of trouble
oh my god a Sukkah there any way to get
here or is it just long
long way back up well I made it seem so
easy when I just jump back down so where
do I go to get back up mmm
it seems to be a way over to the right
there so I'm gonna go so what
that was another operator okay it's
gonna go for it over here okay well this
is all blown I can't get up whew no what
are you talk Oh
how do you have a floating one that is
not fair that is not fair okay God why
is the framerate drop and I'm going for
it hmm oh god there's more stairs over
here I can go up a little bit not far
this didn't go anywhere there was no
point in that that just went exactly
where I was before oh boy these guys
want me dead really did I guess I can
use my should be able to use my glue to
be able to clear the stairs to go up at
the top of this thing but I still don't
even think that's gonna help me the rest
of the way
gotta get so far to go up there's just
no staircase alright we just got to go
for it I can't ah I can't stick the bat
or whatever then we got to go over to
the little gap over here where there was
area that I could stick to and hope oh
hope that they don't come back and see
me oh god I'm gonna be able to do this
jeez oh my god okay oh boy no no no no
no no okay why are the so tiny why did
does it make such tiny blue balls
why doesn't help anybody money we go up
up up up up up up here who save I think
I can make it over there huh okay hi god
dammit you're the one that was causing
me such word go what No
that's not good died oh that's killing
me that's killing me psyche get away
from that oh god no aah oh god that's
fire that's fire
oh god no oh this couldn't have gone any
worse it's gonna have gone any worse and
no worse oh god they're right by me
ooh ooh why is your sewin fire whoa okay
there we go then we go over scooter ski
wolf man if they took out my propulsion
system right before I was able to drop
what is my friend Rob Hey
oh my god where am I oh my god why is it
so hard to look over there oh geez
they're on the way oh boy this tool
woman I'm I'm just gonna have to try to
Oh
friggin point you where do I go I don't
even see where to go Oh am I gonna make
that one okay brick you man for you
Jesus get away from me what did I ever
do to you oh [ __ ] me then Oh God Oh
Frick oh boy oh boy
wha why with the framerate rush oh my
god oh my god oh my god oh my god okay
we're almost there oh my god
where am I going hey no kidding about
the structural why I didn't want to
fight you [ __ ] oh god damn who's
gonna burn me are you oh my god oh [ __ ]
oh geez
okay we're going we're gone we're gonna
we're gonna we're good we're good we're
not good we're not doing good at all
good is the opposite of what we're doing
but we're doing okay
oh hey - I hate you I hate you hate you
open open open open open open open the
manometer oh that sucked
that sucks but I did it look that alarm
went off in the coolant chamber after
you powered the reactor back up the
turbines are hydrogen cool now they're
leaking you take a shot and it's your
lost
it'll be like shooting a grenade at your
feet what okay that that's some positive
reinforcement there do I need to come
talk to you or do I need to go and get
your things now to be the responsible
nice work Markham you'll be an engineer
yet yeah nah get to the lift before I
die in front of me
my legs are fighting on another day but
now ah my vision starting to go too damn
it
hmm all right well I'll try my best you
stay alive I guess is the only thing
like a girl oh but at least I I can get
outside again and when I can get outside
that usually means that I'll be able to
get back to where I need to go look like
you had a rough day huh
all right cool whatever you say man
thank you for that whatever it was
you're great and I love you or whatever
that was right that was a rush that was
rough that was an interesting thing so
what we need to do now is we need to get
back to the closest point that gets me
to both her office and the neuro mod
department and then hopefully that means
that I'm going to get closer to where I
actually need to go because I think they
coincide all into one so let me just
double check my objectives here keys to
the kingdom I need to go to Alec get
Alex's our car arming key in the
Arboretum both of those are actually in
the Arboretum then let's see um in her
office Tallis 1x Syria oh okay so I can
access her office from the Kulin
monitoring room in the power plant
interesting I don't know where gene Fair
is I don't man
groove so many things dude there's a lot
of sidequest it gets a tragedy that I'm
not able to do all the side quests in
this room oh hey how's it going there
okay all right got that one yeah it's a
tragedy that I'm not able to do all of
the side quests in there because it's
like this is such a really cool in-depth
game like they put in so much detail
into this in a lot of free roam and a
lot of ability to move wherever you want
to move and that's something that you
don't see in a lot of games I mean it's
obviously got a little linear narrative
to it and with some variability in there
there's AB options to make choices in
there and you know but it probably
doesn't deviate too far from the
original spectrum of what the story is
going to be but all that aside it's
really cool that they have so much depth
in you because it paints us this
scenario where it is like it's a scary
game of time but also it's a fascinating
game I wouldn't paint it as a pure
horror game either like the premise is
scary but as soon as you become an alien
yourself and you're the monster what's
to be afraid of if you are the monster
but at the same time it's just God is
it's so weird because of how much
they've been able to build in such a
short amount of time and when I'm
fascinated and no one on earth has been
able to look at Tallis and go like hey
something seems to be wrong there huh oh
down there oh I have a limited amount of
time for that only an hour and 43
minutes I thought I was going the right
way I'll be right back I thought I was
going the right way I know oh we got a
duder we got a dude er what you gonna do
dude er huh kind of oh ya know not to do
it not today
today apparently oh my sign has been
nullified get some of this
take this nonce I am i might sigh okay
let's hope I can scan you before you die
a horrible painful death wait what no no
no come scan you okay you get a little
bit left don't die yet until I scan you
and Jerry go mine Jack three that's
probably the thing that does mind
control from the dive on new pad eat ah
oh no don't do that oh I don't want to
church yeah I know suit integrity has
been damaged I get that I felt it when
it hit me in my face all right so I'm
gonna go in here and I'm gonna way got
you guys with your radiation always with
your radiation let's see if I can get a
little more because I got plenty of
these well helping you below buddy and
then it is it is really nice having more
health this is not what I needed at all
but I'm going to throw a recycler charge
in there and see what his wood tube oh
they got sucked in right in there
all right oh no all the materials yeah
this is dr. equi okay lead it to your
office okay I'll remain here until after
you weigh my word what are you and where
are you speaking in Morgan's voice I am
January
Morgan use personal upper
well January sorry
your arrival was a bit of a shock quite
the day today you know if you are
referring to the type and infestation of
tallow Swan doctor II way you are
correct you are one of the few survivors
I guess it's wait is that fabricator
functioning I might be able to make use
of it
with your permission mo January you have
authorization to work at the station
doctor you weigh and manufacture
anything that will assist Morgan in
containing the - I'll remain here in
your office in any return Morgan I may
be able to be abuse well that seemed
like a stiff exchange I make me so mad
sometimes you never listen to me wait
what wait what did you say wait what I'm
so confused why are you mad at me I
thought I did good I thought I did good
anyway no no I think I do good and then
apparently I do one thing that's bad and
then I blow everything up and everybody
dies and then that's the end of it at
all and everybody hates me because I'm
an alien and I make bad decisions
no no no well hopefully we can get to
the bottom of this because I feel like
there are more truths out here that I do
not fully comprehend all right so
hopefully she's still alive in there
because apparently I didn't go too far
for some reason I was drifting off of a
space like that and I don't know why
hello oh god Morgan
hi you surprised the hell out of me
sometimes please right at the neck just
look for the marks it was harder when I
was doing it myself
I see oh god I can breathe again and
feel my legs there are some spots in the
eye but those should clear our blanks
look man I don't even know what pair of
plexus is sounds bad though
good god so nice work Morgan you make
junior engineer yet no yet to the lift
might be careful no telling what got
stirred up in the shake hello and I can
meet you at your office
alright that's soon I'll conduct you
make it your own
so we're I'm in that's good right that's
good because that means that more and
more survivors seem to be collecting at
my office which is good so I could go
that way I'm gonna go this way just
because I want to get it back I wonder
knew he would least finding Michaela it
makes me think the neuro mod expression
didn't erase everything not completely
perhaps particularly strong memories
still leave faint impressions intuitive
feelings or maybe you're simply more
compassionate than I expected hmm are
you sure it wouldn't have been better to
I don't mean to be insensitive but when
she finds out he would tend to destroy
tell us one we should might react
strongly canid there's no way Ornish
dangerous level of explosive gas
detected tank and agreeable steward and
holy flames blow this place sky-high if
they see me ah that's the weird white
why you gotta be such a dick oh god I
shouldn't have come in here at all I
just go down you can crawl along the
bottom find a way yeah looks like I got
away in here get that while I can
welcome to Undertown oh boy oh boy oh
boy oh boy Weiss why is there just why
is there just that there there's sparks
obviously and we're not blowing up them
and done them right there anyway yeah I
have a funny feeling that me and Mikaela
they're like in a previous existence
according to these frickin your mom had
a relationship was holding what was even
the point of coming down here then
I mean it must have been to sneak around
those guys but at the sig dump this
marks everywhere I'm gonna die oh good
one neural mod save why'd you save some
gum after me integrity restored hydrogen
loss reduced by 33% alright whatever
there must be other tanks or otherwise
that would be the last of it but I'm
gonna try to do is I'm not gonna use
that I'm gonna stick to the glue cannon
because I think of all the things it's
gonna be the least amount of explosive
and then hopefully through this tank
integrity restored I get it hydrogen
loss reduced by 33% yeah I freaking get
it okay I already got you so I
understand well here we go I see what's
going on here I don't have a lot of
spare parts whoo I don't have enough to
fix all of them anyway maybe it would
just be best to try to glue my way up
just don't have enough oh I've got I've
got some but I've been spending it all
on like fixing up the stupid turn
breaking story hydrogen loss reduced by
66 performs yeah I guess it's something
good but I just don't have I need two
more to be able to do that oh it's right
down there is there any way that I could
dismantle if I dismantle these I could
get the spare parts if I just aww if i
dismantle this menu dismantle I'll get
three perfect that's perfect right then
I got everything I need and I can do
this
oh that's cool all right so I got that
and then BAM mabushii okay gasps minimal
normal operations may resume pending
supervisor approval all right then well
we got that underway which is gonna be a
boon for us and maybe just maybe I just
averted sure catastrophe at the
explosiveness of this whole place but I
still don't know if it'll blow molding
or not something tells me I might new
art stores I can do that
that sounded like something just noticed
me well don't mind me while I'm hanging
the son of a [ __ ] did you say nice and
calm over in the other world
blurp no that's not the way to do with
bouncing your balls all over the place
in cubed EMU down there and then a scoop
D it gets easier as you go up which
would make sense that better you get out
of the morning Oh No your art and you
know you're not gonna deal with me
because I'm gonna deal with you you
ready for this sumbitch Oh buttons
hit me to do that I meant to do this I
see you here see you up there
you get mo oh well your your your if I
couldn't sell in the darkness all right
yeah who kill him Oh kill him are you
gonna know oh okay now that that that
that lots of goodies around Saul another
another recycler which is awfully nice
of them to get me
I blew these boxes while they were
standing there and they were really
mimics sook and got they're giving me a
plans for a glue cannon right now the
last thing I need
well I got a lot of material out of it
so good for me this was a worthy venture
oh god there's grounding resistors right
here I didn't know that I would have
just gone and done that a long time ago
there's no reason for me to go down
there okay
moving on we got to get back and we got
to get to the main lift because I got a
number-one unlock the neuro mods in
number two I got to carry on to the
Arboretum and then hopefully made up
with Alex who would sound a still oh hi
how's it going there ren-dono Oh dado
friend Oh
whoo that's another one
oh you got sploded oh what's in there
hmm I don't know I can't get in there
enough to glue it so I'm just gonna
leave that for what it is oh I could
have gotten a grounder resistor dragon
routable good you know what I'm gonna do
that because it's right there so I might
as well I totally forgot that any of the
ground over is there not anywhere far
off that I already came from so give me
two seconds to be able to go back and
grab one of these bad boys and then put
it in the slot and be okay you literally
do okay now I got this oh I can't sprint
with this one it's just too heavy for my
alien arms to carry no this one's gonna
be just too girthy for me to actually
drag along the ground behind me no no no
I'm a Wimpy weakling I can fill millions
of type on but not carry this one thing
in a nice jaunty jog hi I don't even
know what this is gonna do boy oh it's
not dark in there anymore apparently but
uh I still don't even know what that did
for me there was a way to get in there
which I don't even know there is there's
a breach detected in there but I don't
see it because it seems to be sealed off
with everything else and there's this
neuromas floating there well that didn't
do me a lot of good and I feel bad about
myself for making the effort to do that
prick
alright fine then we're gonna carry on I
hope that I did the same thing operator
that operated floating around someone
wait on this and get my suit repaired
and then move on trans dark I surprises
places and blown up on its own I mean I
guess you know knowing the future they
would build these stations to be just a
little sturdier to withstand quite a few
things off ubifs and bats around here
but it seems to me that there's a bit of
a problem when the Typhon that's able to
mimic everything just seemed to flood
through the entire station willy-nilly
they didn't quite have the security
concerns that they thought they were but
then again who would like you need an
army to be able to fight all these
things in their best they have a
security force and one more than you
right here
one sweet delicious delectable Morgan
you sure more that's up whoo hello hello
how did you get broken I remember I left
you with love and care oh oh hi that's
why I'm out there okay never mind that
excuse you for being in my way excuse
you for thinking that you could step in
front of me take a glue that on warp
it's over there
what now I need to scan a greater mimic
I thought I would have gotten hundreds
of greater mimics by now oh god there's
someone no die
don't even think about how about ie leva
I don't have enough of those well I try
to mr. out hide so I'm gonna try to not
that but I'll eat that I need that can I
just didn't see nothing I am but a
humble sign they spotted me oh my
disguise it's not as good as I thought
it was Chickasaw humble sign tumbling up
the stairs oh my god how am I not dead
yet I don't think they've noticed okay
tumbling through the sky he's running
away as fast as I can and I'm howdy
[ __ ] ha ha ha I can't believe that
worked
but lo and behold we are finally back
into the talents 1 lobby which has I've
been trying to get back to for a while
now I've been trying hard I would have
gotten there already if I had already
been trying but yeah I was trying as
best as I possibly could so there we
have that whoo alright so we got back
what is this I guess I see where all
that fronts our money goes thank you sir
you're alive EJ you made it chief
engineer illusion what the hell
morganissa no no that is in January
Morgan use personal operator talk about
loving the sound of your own voice so
it's the three of us four of us anyone
else from the labs or psychotronics is
that Morgan's workstation and the
fabricator chief Ellucian please do not
workin come up here when you do the
shops uh I totally forgot I totally
forgot all this love and care about
going to the Arboretum and getting to
this point I should have gone outside
because I totally forgot that there's a
problem in the Arboretum and I gotta go
there anyway whoopee dooby doo doo be
doobie [ __ ] do I thought I was at the
towels one lovey turns out I wasn't
because I'm an idiot and I should I just
followed that path outside and I should
have done that but then I was going to
loop D whoop Dee way because I'm a dummy
woman and I will be right back
once I get outside sorry what I need is
his is he running for my life
oh god you saw me busting because you're
da man I'm smart and you're dumb Oh God
get clued lalala lalalala no there's
something at the bottom of this elevator
going to run away from it very fastly oh
look at me run I am a big [ __ ] and I
care about living and we are outside
just like that just like I promised I
would so I need to go to the Arboretum
no matter what and I think that is what
it is at the top of the tower like what
I was looking for so I'm gonna go up
there
hopefully I know exactly where I'm going
with this one and then if I can deal
with the thing in the elevator then I
can go to the lobby meet them in my
office go to get the neural mod plan
unlocked so they can craft up just out
but low to neural mods which is really
what I wanted this whole time and then
I'll be able to get so next I will see
you in the Arboretum unless something
gets in my way
[Music]
okay go me now come to my graph chef
assuming it still works
okay well I don't want to see you just
yet I got other things to do before I do
that do you fix up my suit I seem to Ram
to my face into a beam where I got to go
over here that's not what I wanted at
all how the hell did you do that [ __ ]
really really you [ __ ] god damn it I
was having a nice time having a chat
with his operator and then you decided
to be a driver Eric thank you for that I
just need I'm running out of healing
juice hmm
also Nicole hog who's that and where why
do I need to do that who hi there Weaver
Armand ignoring over here ok alright so
we're gonna get in here we're gonna
fight that big thing which I am ready to
fight for because I am a smart cookie
that he's capable of combat and able to
been bamboozled people all over the
place also how the hell did they get to
my office how do they do that though I
have no idea but they're there Wilier
than I is I should just done this from
the get-go you just are you get
introduced either you doing good we do
he would ever get that
so I already got that thing old thinker
who this alright so I just need to I
know no do it
gall free oh come on put the scope down
dammit
oh no charge
she songs you shut up god damn it this
weight exactly offers the whales Bam Bam
Bam Bam Bam oh she's oh god whoa try
this again
load that no don't don't don't okay boy
sure gotta go got him just out of range
very close but not quite
[Applause]
right on top of damn thing yeah gotta
get this oh there we go
blasted two freakin pieces reasons nice
work
the lift is responding again that type
and hijack the hardware even the
software running the system all the way
down to the machine code reprogramming
it on the fly fascinating and alarming
you know doing can hatch up the code you
should be fine take the lift if you need
to move quickly between the three main
decks on Talos one it has to stop in the
lobby and down in life support yeah I
should have done that from the get-go
good man I wasn't even ready for that
one okay come on let me in let me in let
me in let me and I gotta get down to the
main lobby man huh the hell's going on
Abigail I'm recording this time you too
Emma it's fine
Danielle's joining us so cover us if we
get into trouble she said yes we
negotiated I had to say yes to some
things too I don't know what that was
all about but again it's all about a
Abigale there she's still live outside
she's just not come inside then that
what you did was I supposed to go
outside and say I know her because I was
outside a lot and I didn't know exactly
where she was but
oh wow here we are oh boy it's gotten
worse down here Oh
oh it's gotten a lot worse oh god oh god
oh god oh this much worse oh this is
much worse Oh much worse okay all right
I'm just gonna skedaddle up to my office
and then hide in there I how how did
they get here how did they get here how
just did you riddle me that one how did
they get here because my turret isn't
even here anymore anything could drag
did Abaddon tell me again how the
decompression happened it was very
sudden Morgan oh god I'm sorry
I was using your workstation I found the
right materials for the glue gun as well
was able to make several canisters I
also found some food on the way up left
it on the desk don't worry they're alien
proof I checked them not witching to be
sure I let you a sample them first
pardon me I'm joking
away I wouldn't willingly expose you to
aliens or anyone else that would be
inhuman huh alrighty then whatever you
say as glue canisters thank you for that
I guess awesome okay your office is
relatively secure come back if you need
to rest or use the fabricator
what do you mean relatively secure how
could it be relatively secure when
there's frickin Typhon everywhere
outside literally everywhere outside
well I guess it's best that I can offer
a limit or cycle this down and get some
bang for Gator stuff going cuz there's
like two safe houses now there's one
wherever I was putting up those nerds in
the busy people in my I never told you
why I altered my medical records okay I
know you were so sure when you're
lecturing me Morgan saying I was selfish
and my father he was imprisoned for
questioning the Soviet intervention in
India many prisoners are lost in
Siberian labor camps but my father
vanished
the only thing I knew for certain was
Transtar with recruiting volunteers from
those labor camps I came here because of
you
and Alex and your experiments to find
him and now I know he was here I noticed
on your computer you found a set of
names and ID numbers from psychotronics
from dr. Gallegos the Russian volunteers
were never referenced by name but I was
able to match an ID to my father we can
pull up his records archive experiment
logs I've already asked a great deal of
you but if you could find that archive
in deep storage I'll finally know what
happened to my father
his name was Yuri on dronov V 0 1 0 6 5
5 3 2 yeah remember that god it's so
weird because like Aroo inertia why
Russian volunteers
well their russian penal system is quite
unforgiving and there are lions with the
translate interest
economically coincided it was Catherine
OU's idea their mother and Alex saw the
advantages so they were murdered because
of political convenience and cost
savings the term murder I would dispute
but I do not wish to lie to you these
two factors made them good candidates
for the research develop sorry oh my god
oh my god oh my god I'm just gonna just
get a quick load about that didn't do
nothing of that that was not again it's
really easy to press that button that is
not intentional I want to be very clear
that is not intentional it's just it's
like the slightest if you just barely
that right mouse button it is like going
off like I am sorry I have more immunity
typical of Alexis from here the content
of the mix our system isn't dumb only a
flesh and blood person could handle the
responsibility I presume okay you know
what I'm just gonna yeah that's gonna be
the end of it for now imma just end this
here before everything it was crazy
again so that is all the time I got for
prey we are getting very close to the
end of the game all we got to do is go
talk to Alex there's a ton of side
quests there's probably like more side
quests than there is the main game but
unfortunately I'm just not gonna be able
to do all that so I'm gonna do what I
can
don't even know if I'm gonna be able to
find her father or the records of her
father but I'm going to do my best for
now so thank you everybody so much for
watching let me know how i'm doing the
comments below and as always i'll see
you in the next video bye
[Music]